aluminum a metal which has become
the pacesetter of the 20th century
aluminum is light strong easily fabricated
and versatile today it has greater versatility
because many types of finishes are available
finishes offering new possibilities for tomorrow
today only the finish on a window tomorrow
perhaps the dramatic answer to an automotive
problem today a compact the shimmering color
and texture tomorrow may ride the rails today
a wear resisting finish on giftware and tomorrow
might be the answer for decorative trim maybe this
finish for the instrument panel and fittings
a soft satin finish like this for my picture
frame we'll use this finish for porch furniture
from today's accomplishments come tomorrow's ideas
there's news in aluminum finishes inspiration
for tomorrow from the datelines of today
dateline new york city towering lines
of the buildings at rockefeller center
are admired by visitors from near and
far vertical lines are emphasized by aluminum
spandrels finished in a neutral gray tone
the architects specified this
shade to achieve the effect desired
how was it possible to meet the architect's ideas
on color and texture there's news in the answer
pebbles soap and water cascading against castings
of aluminum friction of stone against metal
thousands of tiny impressions creating a dark gray
color a simple mechanical device to obtain the
desired tone an illustration of the possibilities
which lie in mechanical finishing methods
variations of mechanical finishes can be used to
produce dozens of different tones and textures
finishes in themselves or textures
and lusters for any overlying finish
perhaps the most common of all
mechanical methods is buffing
polishing polishing with buffing
compounds against a revolving wheel
the smoothness and brightness of the finish
depend on the combination of buffing compound
and buffing wheel or belt these finishes
range from a high gloss to a soft satin finish
a wire brush provides the familiar scratch brush
finish with its various effects the texture
of the surface depends on the fineness
and stiffness of the wire in the brush
sand blasting is a fast and inexpensive method
of giving castings a clean uniform surface
variations in the kind and coarseness of abrasive
give finishes with variety and texture and shade
the tumbling barrel is a practical method of
removing burrs and other roughness from small
parts hard steel shot with a little soap and
water lubricant tumbled in the barrel results
in a smooth and burnished surface on the product
hundreds of which can be finished in the same
economical operation after one or more tumblings
the product is finished and ready for market
mechanical finishes are seen in many architectural
details spandrels windows doors mailboxes railings
grills these mechanical finishes are used to
obtain the desired tone texture and harmony
in almost any american home are examples of
several mechanical finishes on aluminum wear
hand hammered trays familiar utensils color buffed
the many different mechanical finishes suggest
more combinations and variations ideas for
tomorrow from the processes we know today
sidewalks of the nation truck
drivers are rolling out the barrels
and hoisting them with ease today they're aluminum
imagine a good looking beer barrel
but why bother with the finish at all
purely for its merchandising appeal it wouldn't
pay to spend much money finishing a barrel
so they found the answer a chemical treatment like
the mechanical finishes this chemical treatment
changes only the appearance of
the surface not its durability
it is an acid dip followed by water rinsing this
chemical treatment repairs and cleans the inside
ready for the beer gives the
outside an attractive silvery finish
another widely used chemical treatment is the
caustic etch this produces a frosted finish
on stampings forgings and castings on name
plates the words graduations and designs
can be engraved on aluminum
by another chemical treatment
a chemical solution etches the parts not protected
by a stop off outlining the design on the surface
a great many products today
such as aircraft gasoline tanks
are finished by one of the group of chemical
treatments known as the al rock processes
by chemical means an oxide film is applied
which is thicker than the natural film and
gives greater protection in one of the al
rock processes an alkaline chromate solution
is used to oxidize the surface a second
chemical treatment seals the oxide coating
al rock coatings are used for both
protective and decorative purposes
these gasoline tanks are given an el rock coating
to protect them from the
corrosive effects of aviation fuel
and on outboard motors exposed parts get
better protection because of the alrock process
the finish on these motors takes a real beating
subjected to spray vibration and constant exposure
the al rock coating here serves a double purpose
it bonds the paint the metal and adds to the
protection afforded by the paint rivets are often
given a protective al rock coating the al rock
processes as well as the other chemical treatments
provide economical methods of finishing either for
protection or appearance methods in use today
which will provide material for tomorrow
brooklyn new york countless lives are destined
to be saved tomorrow by the contents of cases
packed here today with the modern miracle drug
penicillin penicillin packed in glass bottles
is protected by aluminum seals and aluminum
dust caps aluminum with an enamel finish
aluminum caps and shields with various organic
finishes such as lacquers and enamels are
familiar to all they illustrate the virtues of
aluminum not only in protecting the contents
but in holding paint outstanding developments in
organic finishes on aluminum have been made in the
packaging field aluminum foil and collapsible
tubes are attractively decorated by enameling
printing and lacquering here's eye appeal
sales appeal aluminum takes and holds paint
well but surface preparation is important for many
articles a thorough cleaning with a grease solvent
is sufficient for harder usage a chemical
treatment may be used for instance
the aluminum tank of this truck was sprayed with
a dilute solution of phosphoric acid rinsed and
dried zinc chromate primer was applied followed by
top coats of enamel so today organic finishes are
applied to aluminum or any of its alloys another
development which holds promise for tomorrow
rain and fog ceiling zero the ground is
completely obscured while somewhere up there
an airliner wings its way home aboard
the liner passengers are untroubled
or the pilots will guide the airplane safely home
with the help of new types of electronic apparatus
the tiny electrical impulses of these
devices need an excellent conductor today
lightweight aluminum is being used
aluminum plated with silver to provide
the low electrical resistance needed in the
contacts electroplating of aluminum has arrived
yes aluminum can be successfully electroplated
the secret is in the surface preparation
special treatment is required for aluminum
in one method of preparation the aluminum surface
is first thoroughly cleaned it is next rinsed and
then immersed in a sodium zincate solution after
this comes another rinsing then it is ready
for plating in solutions and with techniques
much the same as those used for other metals
primarily electroplates on aluminum are
used for appearance and resistance to wear
plated aluminum is successfully
answering many problems
as in this fabricated handle it is opening new
fields for tomorrow from the findings of today
with the pacific fleet navy
planes by special orders
resisted corrosion during long months
of service in the second world war
taking off on countless patrol and bombing
missions amid salt spray in the tropics
or in the frozen north these plains stood the
gap by special navy orders the critical parts
of every plane were given an anodic finish
for added protection and as a base for paint
the anodic treatment forms a hard protective
oxide coating on the surface of the aluminum
by an electrochemical process earlier we saw
that the al rock treatment made such a coating by
chemical means the electrochemical treatment makes
a better and stronger coating most practical and
durable of the anodic finishes is that known as
the alumalite finish let's see just how hard it is
half of this test piece is unfinished the other
half has been treated by the alumalite process
a rotating wheel of abrasive
turns equally on both halves
after 3 000 revolutions the abrasive wheel
has left a worn track on the unfinished half
while the alumalite portion shows hardly
anywhere thanks to its hard thick oxide coating
typical operations in the
production of alumalite finishes
include a cleaning bath
followed by a rinse in water
next the articles are inaudibly oxidized in acid
electrolyte for a period from 10 to 30 minutes
the final step is the sealing of the finish so
that it won't absorb stains and for increased
resistance to corrosion big installations
of equipment for applying alumalite finish
are in use by many industries this is a production
line operation in the finish of aluminum furniture
all over america products of aluminum with
a luma light finish are resisting wear
furniture and accessories
finished by the alumalite process
are attractive and durable yes here at
last is a metal that's easy to clean
even those sticky remains come off with ease
because of the hardness of the alumalite finish
in the production of alumalite finish
we have seen that at one stage it had
to be sealed to keep it from staining this
absorptive characteristic can be an advantage
if before sealing the coating is dipped in a dye
solution it takes on color just as cloth is dyed
the dye actually becomes part of the coating
in this example a resist was used on the areas
which were not to be colored these colored
aluminum name plates illustrate a practical use of
the alumalite process alumalite finish in colors
offers many possibilities in terms of beauty and
in terms of practical use for instance colored
fittings on airplane hydraulic lines for quick
identification name plates and easy to read dials
the dyed alumalite finishes are best for
interior uses when brilliant colors are wanted
alzac reflectors are produced by another anodic
treatment closely allied to the alumalite process
85 reflective efficiency can be attained by an
electrolytic treatment the surface is protected
by a transparent anodic coating a regular
cleaning will keep the alzac finish bright
the oxide film of the alumalite finish
similarly will retain its beauty with
only an occasional wiping your ice cube
trays illustrate a combination of finishes
they are first given a frosted surface by caustic
dip then finished by the alumalite process
and this permanent license plate is a
combination of enamel and alumalite finishes
a striking example of the beauty of the alumalite
finish is this escalator housing the pleasing
tones and textures were produced
by a combination of mechanical
and alumalite finishes many variations of tone and
texture are possible through the use of mechanical
or chemical methods followed by a lumalite finish
accomplishments of today ideas for tomorrow
dateline tomorrow from today's finish that stands
the weather tomorrow's lawn and garden furniture
today the satin finish of a tea set tomorrow the
impressive lobby of a building today silver plated
aluminum radio equipment tomorrow plated aluminum
hardware today aluminum foil to protect cigarettes
tomorrow an evening wrap of aluminum cloth
aluminum finishes that make it more beautiful
and more useful finishes for protection finishes
for decoration from the accomplishments of today
will come new products new uses
news for the datelines of tomorrow